breathtaking
absolutely breathtaking
today i'm headed to the monument valley
high school in utah to be a part of the
blessing ceremony for peace and
positivity for the football team the
school and the surrounding area their
football field is one of the most epic
stadiums in the country
you know get this rum from
you know it's been tough with covet i
know you guys had your season canceled
last year glad you guys finally get to
step back on this field so uh i hope you
guys have a great season you guys ready
to throw yeah yeah all right let's do it
i'm gonna give you a set hut and you
roll set up
set up
there we go so you're the first female
quarterback in utah history yeah how's
that it's nice what are your plans for
this year you just battling with this
guy try to beat him out yeah
okay i like it i like a little family
competition see what you got
it's a nice throw
every year we do the ceremony so we have
the fireplace going to bless the
building on our teachers football field
when we're done doing the prayer you're
going to come up here and bless yourself
and just think positive what you're
going to do this year
set your goals thank you for talking to
the young people here on the naval
reservation he's part of us and part of
us on the reservation
you don't get this in california i mean
the red rocks the big mountains it's a
wonderful site i am actually a native
american myself i'm part of the
potawatomi tribe
i am honored they invited me to this
beautiful ceremony